for the past two years the born this way
foundation co-founded by lady gaga has
immersed itself in the las vegas
community to bring more
mental wellness resources to our city
the executive director of the foundation
maya smith joins us now
to talk not just about what las vegas
residents have been dealing with this
past year due to the pandemic
but about the city's youth and their
silent struggle
maya thank you so much for joining us
it's been a challenging year
why do you think this time has been
particularly hard on young people
thank you so much for that
i think a period of time for young
people
everyone this is the first that we've
been
surviving a pandemic um we're living in
a world of
um of uh unknown circumstances and young
people are dealing that
with them with grace and so proud of the
young people in las vegas who are
prioritizing their mental health um i
just wanted to come on today
to remind people that however they're
feeling is
okay that there are resources their
support
and there are um there's community for
each of you so please
check out foreign soy dot foundation
we're so proud of the network that we've
built
in las vegas and the tools and resources
that we've created for you
now you yourself have been impacted by
suicide losing your father
um several years ago are there resources
that can help
people not just that are struggling but
to help spot
signs that a loved one may be struggling
silently
absolutely and my family is just one of
um most families really these days have
been touched
uh by suicide given the surge in
suicides
and uh there are many resources for
someone who's struggling one of
one of the most important ones that
we've seen is the work of the national
council of behavioral health
with mental health first aid we need to
get much more proactive about talking
about mental health
not just times in christ of in times of
crisis but proactively as well
and mental health first aid is an
incredible training program that allows
you to do that
we're also working with an amazing
organization called jack.org on their be
their
curriculum be there allows you to lead
into hard conversations
ask the right questions and know the
resources to support yourself or a loved
one who may be struggling
great information before we let you go
tell me what the please stay
pledge is i would love to the police
state pledge was created
for young people by young people and
it's an invitation
to get through the good days and the
hard days and everything in between
together
we need to just more simply talk about
surviving and thriving and the police
state pledge is a partnership between
warner soy foundation and find your
anchor
please visit us at us and please join me
in agreeing to stay we need you here you
matter
and the world needs your voice maya
thank you so much and thank you for what
you do for more information
you can go to born this way dot
foundation thank you so much
thank you great information right there
thanks mercedes all right there's more
las vegas now just ahead